hallo mein name ist willkommen hier wird
oft die website z 0 zugesendet auf
dieser website passiert wohl irgendwas
das heißt wir gehen auf dieser website
passieren komische dinge wie
beispielsweise supergeil danke für die
empfehlung freunde wie können wir uns
auf fremdem platz
[Musik]
damit haben wir heute wohl einen neuen
rekord aufgestellt wie schnell in einem
video die niveaulosigkeit der riskiert
herzlichen glückwunsch luca blicken
wieder auf fremdem
[Musik]
der denkt wohl auch dass wir wieder die
niveaulosigkeit erreicht haben ich habe
ja damals mal ein video gemacht was sich
sinnlose webseiten genannt habe das
verlange ich euch mal da ich muss
wirklich sagen dass ich zu dem zeitpunkt
dachte dass es nichts dümmeres mehr gibt
allerdings
[Musik]
oh mein gott wir reden noch weiter das
ist tatsächlich cool ich liebe solche
solche momentaufnahmen dunkel
neben schwarz weiß abend nach dem
gegener großstadt
obwohl von der grafik hat tatsächlich
recht scheiße ist habt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch bei meinen weight
loss gemerkt dass ich übelst lust hat
das ganze mit seiner band mit seiner
mutter zu unterlegen und dann mit dem
wir machen weiter alles klar alles klar
als er alles klar
klar das ist tatsächlich wieder ganz
geil deshalb die erde
die muss klar sein weil ich gerade auf
tour
bei dieser sache weil es jetzt
tatsächlich nicht was das so genau soll
hey da kommt ein tief von rechts rein
gelaufen der ist nackt
[Musik]
jetzt gibt einfach nur noch für krasse
techno sachen packt mich war nämlich ein
bisschen ab august in ihrem inneren
haben oper milupa wenn ihr wissen wollt
wie es aussieht wenn ich im prozent
in siem reap aufgenommen ein brett
vertraut wie aber hier raus man meine
güte
[Musik]
wo ist sie
ist das manuell kann oder sie ist
schreiben ob du es bist kein schweiß ok
oh wunder hoffen
[Musik]
nun sind wir tatsächlich bei der
dummheit schlechthin angekommen ich
denke ich habe ich zu viel versprochen
mit
wollt ihr dass ich noch mal ein teil von
z 0 r hochladen
schreibt es mir und kotzt in die
kommentare das leid da für jeden leykauf
ich mir fünf neue lambos chips